Whitehouse budgets are both really good
inside into what a president sort of
values but at the same time almost
meaningless in the sense that whatever
the budget proposes either needs to have
the funding appropriated by Congress or
needs to be made into law by Congress so
while a budget might say we want funding
for I don't know abortion on demand
until the kid is three or whatever right
I mean just make whatever you want up
out of thin air that would tell us a lot
about the priorities of the
administration if they put something
like that in a budget but unless you get
it passed into law and or funded
depending on what we're talking about it
doesn't really matter so we now have a
new White House budget for 2019 from the
Trump administration it's a very
political document and insofar as
politics matter and they do we should
analyze it and this particular budget
that we've received from Donald Trump is
a deficit exploding abortion and by it
speaking of abortions as I use that
example I'm talking about the second
definition of an abortion something
badly carried out not a medical abortion
and that is exactly what this is Donald
Trump vowed time and again to reduce the
debt and not run up deficits many many
times on the campaign trail Trump said
to Alex Jones in an interview we have to
end the four hundred billion dollar
deficit that we were running at the time
Trump said in March of 2016 with the
Washington Post that only he would be
able to get us out of the deficit and
that he would do it and he would run
such a surplus that he would pay off the
entire twenty trillion dollar national
debt within ten years
however Trump's tax cut plan we already
know is going to add about a trillion
and a half to the deficit and this new
budget is going to add about four
hundred billion dollars more to the
deficit on a yearly basis and Trump is
again doing the opposite of what he said
that he would do and he's doing it in
ways that he promised he wouldn't write
this budget if carried out as written
would explode the deficit so much
Trump himself is on record numerous
times saying I'm not going to do it in
fact remember this tweet from Donald
Trump in 2015 where he said I was the
first and only potential Republican
candidate to state there will be no cuts
to Social Security Medicare and Medicaid
the budget cuts funding for Medicaid by
250 billion dollars over the next 10
years many departments would see budget
cuts that includes the State Department
and the EPA and the Interior Department
and this in terms of the values it
represents it's actually seen as good by
committed trumpets they want really
small government they want government
doing as little as possible and we'll
talk about this a little bit more later
but Trump also wants to cut cut funding
for the Corporation for Public
Broadcasting which funds PBS and NPR cut
funding for the National Endowment for
the Arts cut the Community Development
Block Grant program it's all gone in
Trump's budget and it tells us the
values which include a repeal of
Obamacare that is still also going on
but who gets more money somebody must
get more money from a Donald Trump
budget right well yeah the Defense
Department gets more money and Veterans
Affairs gets more money there's 18
billion dollars in funding in Trump's
new budget for the Mexican border wall
which I'm confused now because I thought
Mexico was going to pay for I guess not
if the White House is budget is approved
you will be paying for it through your
taxes and it includes that crony
capitalist infrastructure plan that
Trump has been talking about now for so
long asking for two hundred billion
dollars for that the details of which
I've talked about before and we can sort
of analyze in its own story
now the 85 billion for veterans medical
care and the 17 billion for opioid
crisis related spending I actually think
that that's a good thing but by and
large this is an absolutely disastrous
budget it also adds money to expand the
number of undocumented immigrants that
can be detained and held by ice
at any given time so nothing at all
surprising here in terms of the values
that the budget communicates but there
are some tricks being played here one
example is the budget claims that by
spending 200 billion dollars on
infrastructure spending
they will stimulate a trillion and a
half dollars in total infrastructure
spending so this implies a multiplier of
7.5 right
it's absolutely imaginary okay if if
Trump's infrastructure plan were not a
crony capitalist handout as we've talked
about before it would have a positive
multiplier effect right for every dollar
that the government spends on
infrastructure you would get some
multiple of that back in economic
stimulus but the multiplier would never
even in the best case be 7.5 and the way
Trump wants to do it it's definitely not
going to be anywhere close to that
and so sort of as designed by Trump this
is going to be really really good
for his buddies with the contracts that
they're going to be able to get from
themselves for themselves but the White
House budget is embarrassingly
overstating the economic stimulus of
this it comes out of thin air it's
completely bogus and it's nonsense so
when we look at a budget like this what
we really have to think about is not so
much this is what we're going to be
spending it's more what would this
administration do if they had a sort of
wish list that could become reality in
terms of spending and it is really
really bad and I've been saying this for
a while Pat Congress sets the budget and
controls the spending Republicans don't
really want to pass a true budget where
they sit down and they say okay let's do
a line by line analysis let's rethink
our priorities let's do the tough work
of doing this they don't want to do that
and they don't really have an incentive
to do that because that's a lot of work
they benefit politically from being able
to say hey here's five things we're
cutting funding from and the trumpets
are going to cheer and here's five
things we're adding funding for and the
trumpets are going to cheer
and it's a way to toss the political
football again without actually sitting
down and really three rethinking the
entire budget yeah and the public
doesn't think about it in terms that
these things may not equal out so if you
raise the military spending by a hundred
billion dollars and then you cut
something that's negligible by and large
like the Corporation for Public
Broadcasting yep in people's heads they
say they look at it as the same thing
sure right so you're cutting three
programs and adding the two programs and
people think that that balance is out
but it certainly does I would actually
argue that even if you added a hundred
billion in one place and took a hundred
billion from another place the total
economic impact of that might not be
zero some in the sense that if you take
money away from more economically
stimulative programs and put it into
programs that are less economically
stimulative you might move a hundred
billion from one place to another and
still not come out at zero and by the
way Bernie Sanders plan of providing
free education public university
education yeah for all Americans was
estimated about seventy five billion
dollars and he had a way to pay for it
showed by attacks on Wall Street
speculation but we just add another 100
billion dollars to the military budget
and no one asks questions about it
there's never a question there's that
you can't question that because then
you're unpatriotic and you don't want
the country to succeed absolutely
horrible budget let's think about it
really as a political document more so
than an actual budget because it's not
going to pass as such and we'll follow
the process of it through Congress the
video you just finished watching was
made possible by you through the
membership program you can sign up for
membership at david pakman.com slash
membership we are viewer supported
independent media you can use the coupon
code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership